[Music]
tadam her name is Tran JD Joe Mago that
is Long Legs J bigot yeah
my hometown is London I'd say the best
thing about London and English people in
general is too far like cents a tumor
and the fact that we don't take
ourselves too seriously I make myself
laugh I think on specularly my son makes
me laugh secret about me but then it
wouldn't be a secret that's the whole
point of secrets Kindle was supposed to
go so yeah but you have to really know
how to roll with the punches with my
family like we are very we have like
very Byzantine are and like if you don't
have thick skin you're not one of the
one
[Music]
love I think love is such a beautiful
things that you should experience every
day with relish with love with yourself
having your job loving the people around
you your environment the world so I've
been did something pure and something
that everybody needs to have more my
greatest is when I was growing up my one
of my greatest fear was dying I was like
constantly thinking about death I'd like
constituting that my mom from a guy like
I was just scared of death and now I'm
not so scared about anymore I guess now
growing up I would say of like failing
a new life is laughter and seeing happy
and loved them being around your loved
one and Happiness seeing at home
I haven't Sunday dinner and like what my
mom does like a Sunday roast or like do
stewed chicken and rice and peas and
reminds me of like my great-grandma
bhardwaj really placed - so yeah
I was in Tokyo and I was had a bit of a
breakdown on like crying and really
upset and he came over and concertinas
like mommy you shouldn't be crying and
let nobody make you cry you're so
beautiful when you like who's the same
you know just like let me go Sophie
before and I shouldn't cry and as I make
you happy and I was I really liked
hi I'm good on and this is gone in UK
please subscribe